Clark County getting closer to creating
the last and memorial for one October
right at the site of the Route 91
Harvest Festival and today the final
Design Concepts were unveiled a news now
reporter Brian Mills shows us what the
final Memorial could look like and he
tells us when it could be completed
this is not only ours but it's our
future so that we never forget one
October 2017 58 lives lost and countless
more changed forever the Clark County
Commission appointed a committee to
develop a permanent Memorial to remember
those who perished on Monday they got
one step closer to making that a reality
County Commissioner Jim Gibson we know
that we have friends and loved ones that
are around us who are suffering yet
because of the loss or the injuries that
were sustained all of that is sobering
and all of that makes this moment so
important that we need to get it right
this is one of five designs unveiled
today here at the Clark County
Government Center rotunda with the next
step looking for public input and then a
design presentation by all five design
teams later in June County Commissioner
Marilyn Kirkpatrick explains why this is
a lengthy process people had designs
within three days of of all of this and
I can tell you that none of them compare
to what we see here today and the detail
of really what was important to folks I
think came out and helped people heal
along the way I don't know how you would
rank these obviously it'll happen and
they'll do a good a good job of it we
trust them to do that the budget and
timeline for construction won't be set
until a final design has been chosen by
the one October Memorial committee which
is expected in the fall reporting in
downtown Las Vegas Brian will eight news
now now if you'd like to see the designs
for yourself they're right on display
there at the Clark County rotunda and
now on June 14th now through June 14th
each design team will hold a
presentation about their design
proposals then on the next day there
will be a survey which will go out to
get the Public's feedback and you can
see all those designs right on
8newsnow.com